[Music]
foreign
do you know what color it glows when Old
Town calls its Banners To War
green
hey guys Pete here today I'll be talking
about House of the dragon's fifth
episode we light The Way the final
episode in the extended prologue we've
been navigating through to better
understand all the major players in this
story's motivations it's a fast-moving
hour of Television that answers the
question that's been on all of our minds
for the past week what could go wrong at
a royal wedding in The Game of Thrones
Universe much and more much and more we
also see Damon solve a problem viserys
continue to fall apart Kristen Cole take
a swing in a miss and queen Allison
reached the end of her rope in relation
to her teenage best friend raniera as
far as what I've read this is the last
time we're going to see Millie Alcock
and Emily Carey in these roles and I
suppose after this episode things do all
seem to be in place so that we can jump
forward in time to see if princess
rainey's fears that the realm won't
accept her niece for Nera become and
queen are correct I'll be getting into
what happened and all of that and I'll
be talking about the source material but
as always I won't be giving away any
future spoilers in this video and with
that out of the way let's get into it
the episode opens with Damon finally
following his brother's advice to go
back to runestone where we meet his wife
lady Ria Royce contrary to a statement
about this sheep being prettier than the
women in the veil which is something he
said in King's Landing but it's made its
way back to her in reality she turns out
to be good looking and despite his never
consummating their marriage and not
really ever spending any time here she
has a pretty solid read on who he is in
another one of those scenes where he
doesn't have any dialogue she picks up
the slack re-establishing everything
that's wrong with their marriage and at
least from her experience what's wrong
with him personally because she's so
intent on pushing his buttons there is
some sense of ambience ambiguity about
if this could have gone a different way
still though his marriage is a
significant obstacle to Damon advancing
himself and it doesn't seem all that
likely that he was coming to repair
their marriage and just snapped in the
moment so it's not that surprising when
he picks up the rock to finish the job
after she's thrown from her horse her
final statement of I knew you couldn't
finish Craven may have been a button too
far but this is Damon making himself an
eligible bachelor again and it's
interesting for book readers because
this is the second week in a row that
the show clarified a situation that was
left up to interpretation and in both
cases it skewed towards the more extreme
option it really makes me wonder about
some future events that are still to
come at Sea his brother viserys is
looking ill and we get our first look at
Lionel strong wearing the hand of the
Kingpin we knew that he'd have to
replace Otto after what happened at the
end of the last episode and Lionel was
presented as his best option the king
appears to be seasick but then it also
seems to be related to everything else
that's going on with him which has been
progressing since the second episode
back at the red keep we do see his
previous hand Auto Hightower getting
ready to leave and he has a final
conversation with his daughter Allison
of course she doesn't want to see him go
and he takes that opportunity to twist
the knife a little by telling her that
she's the one that made it possible when
she chose rhaenyra she tries to explain
and after all her good friend who she
does trust did go as far as swearing on
her dead mother But Otto says that you
wanted to believe her just like her
father did and you have to imagine that
this makes the Betrayal sting that much
more in the process of defending her
decision she tells him he shouldn't have
been so intent on making aegon air which
in the book's version of events is the
thing that led to his removal but he
fires back that the king will die maybe
not tomorrow maybe not next month but
he's not going to live to be an old man
and all the Visual Evidence seems to be
backing that up and the point is that if
renera takes the throne there will be
war and we'll hear rainey's echoed this
later which these are two characters
that have their own motivations
especially Otto but they're also very
close to power and understand how things
work in this universe so they're
probably not completely wrong
the most important thing he does here
though is he plants a seed he says to
secure her claim she'll have to put
Allison's children to the sword and this
could be something that the young Queen
never considered if renera is trying to
hold on to power if she's trying to hold
on to her Birthright then a simple
solution is to eliminate other potential
heirs it's a gruesome thought but you
could see how someone who had a stake in
that power remaining where it is could
come up with this as a solution he
leaves her by saying that the time is
coming either you prepare aegon to rule
or you cleave to rhaenyra and pray for
mercy and we know he's telling her this
at a time when her ability to trust in
what raniera says will be tested he does
give her a hug goodbye which seems
Earnest but they have such a strange
father-daughter relationship that it
still seems somewhat Hollow and now
standing in front of the red keep there
is a real sense that she's alone I think
you could read read this as he loves his
daughter but he can't express that he
doesn't know how to and although he's
lost his position all those years of
holding it would mean that he still has
influence he still knows the Power
Players he would still have reach but he
will be leaving the castle itself based
on the decisions he's made I doubt many
fans will miss him but this is a loss
for Allison who now finds herself
surrounded by those kooky targaryens
right on time Lara strong the son of the
new hand injects himself into her life
as a possible Ally when he has a
conversation with her in the godswood
which appears to be where she likes to
spend her time he talks about a plant
that's native to braavos that's growing
in the garden referring to it as an
outsider among the natives not unlike a
high tower in the middle of all those
targaryens and it's almost as if this is
exactly the kind of thing that she might
really be receptive to hearing about
right at the this moment he reveals
quite a lot about who he is in this
interaction that he knows so much about
the plant says he's educated and his
line when one is never invited to speak
one learns instead to observe says a lot
about his Mo he comes off as extremely
calculated when he brings up renera he
makes clear accusations by bringing up
the moon tea that the grand maester took
to her room without clarifying what the
maester was doing there and he backs off
each time he senses that Allison might
Focus her anger on him he's presented as
an unassuming character but I think it's
pretty clear by the way this all plays
out that there's a lot more going on
under the surface when the king arrives
at house valarian's high tide there's no
one there to meet him just Leonor and
Joffrey Elon moth sparring in the front
yard when Lionel objects to the lack of
a welcome party Lena comes out to take
him to her father we see that Corliss is
playing politics a bit he's arranged it
so that he would meet the king in front
of the Driftwood Throne which is the
ancient High seat of house valarian he
brings up the news of the death of
Damon's wife and after they go around
about that viserys makes his proposal
that Lenor will marry his daughter in
air renera Corliss does want to get some
details straight and they decide that
the couple's first born will follow
renera in the line of succession
regardless of gender but in the
westerosi tradition they will be born
Valerian until one of them takes the
throne which they'll do as targaryens
vasera says dragons will rule the realm
for the next hundred years just as they
have for the previous century
out on the beach the royal couple to be
talk and raniera lets him know that she
knows he's not interested in women she
proposes that they go through with the
marriage to do their Duty for their
fathers but once it's done they can do
whatever they want he can keep his lover
Joffrey and she can keep hers when he's
alone with his partner they agree that
this is better than they could have
hoped for but they do wonder who her
Paramore is back inside rainy's worries
that they're putting their son in danger
because she was passed over she knows
that a large part of the realm will
likely reject rhaenyra and in her words
knives will come out for her her husband
and their children much in the same way
that Otto told Allison that her children
wouldn't be safe corlies points out that
many of the Lords already pledge
themselves to her but his wife reminds
him that that all happened before there
was a male Heir together their families
do control the largest navy and half of
the world's dragons so he's confident
they can just Crush anyone that tries to
move against them and while this may be
the case Rainey seems averse to further
conflict or a prolonged War because in
the end what's it all for it's about
power but Corliss tries to reframe it as
Justice for her being passed over back
at the Council of 101 and the takeaway
here is that her concerns are legitimate
on the way back to King's Landing
Kristen Cole makes his move he asks the
princess to run away with him saying
they could leave all of this behind and
see the world together they could have a
marriage for love not for the crown and
he points out all the ways that she's
told him that this might be something
that she wants but he's catastrophically
underestimated what she would be giving
up for as much as she likes to complain
about it she is in line to be the most
powerful woman in the world and she
tells them I am the crown or I will be
and do you think I would throw it all
away to go off and just be a nobody
basically and what's interesting here is
that in her mind she has this already
figured out so you know she has to marry
someone sir lanor will make a fine
husband especially because he's not
interested in being her husband in that
way and in that they have this deal in
place this is something that Kristen
doesn't take well saying you want me to
be your [ __ ] and I think this is
something that makes sense to a point I
understand why he reacts this way in
this situation he took a big chance he
planned this out and he got rejected she
says I want this to continue as it began
with you as my sworn protector my white
knight and that tracks I mean when
you're born a princess why shouldn't you
get everything just as you want it his
problem is that he took this oath and he
broke it and that white cloak was
essentially all he had in the world he
thought if they were married he might be
able to restore his honor and when she
explains hey look the iron throne's
bigger than both of us it makes it
pretty clear where his honor lands on
the list of things that she's worried
about here and in the end he walks away
in in disgust when they returned to
King's Landing we see viserys fall down
in the yard with Allison looking on
because of the seeds that Laris planted
she summons Kristen to her Chambers to
try to learn more about what happened
with Damon because of his guilty
conscience Kristen admits that he slept
with the princess he explains that it
was her idea but he doesn't see that as
an excuse he just asked that instead of
gouting or torturing him that she'll
show some mercy and sentence him to
death the queen is completely caught off
guard like she didn't see this coming at
all and after she puts all the pieces
together in her head she just dismisses
him because what else can she actually
say here we also have a scene with
viserys in his Chambers with grand
maester Melos working with a new maester
named Orwell the king looks absolutely
terrible and at this point I'm not sure
if they're trying to show us that Melos
is actually not up to the task of taking
care of him or what's going on because
he's not that old and he's just falling
apart he has a conversation with the
hand about his legacy which to me
indicates that he's worried that he
might not be long for the world then we
see the Valerian Fleet arriving with
raineys on her dragon melees and her son
Lenor on sea smoke melees was first
written by beceris and Damon's mother
Alyssa Targaryen and there are even
stories of her strapping her sons to her
chest to take them flying when they were
babies rhaenys claimed the dragon after
her death and has written her ever since
in episode 3 we saw Lenor riding sea
smoke in battle at the stepstones and it
felt like a little bit of a missed
opportunity because there's another
Dragon Rider in this family but based on
the trailer for the upcoming episode I
guess they were reserving that for a
later reveal as I mentioned at the
beginning the big question going in is
what could possibly go wrong at a royal
wedding in Westeros we see that the king
is making a show of it and we see the
various families arrive the Lannisters
and the high Towers when we see Jason
Lannister come up to address the king we
realize that Allison hasn't arrived yet
she's not sitting next to her husband so
Gerald Royce tries to get a word in
about his cousin Ria but gets
interrupted by the dramatic arrival of
the belarian family let's just say know
how to make an entrance what's funny is
that as dramatic as it is they're
followed by Damon who steals their
Thunder because everyone seems a little
surprised that he's there if you'll
remember when his brother exiled him at
the end of the last episode he was
pretty serious about him not coming back
the fact that beceros had to have a
chair and a place setting brought in
indicates that they weren't expecting
him but Damon timed things pretty well
to set up a situation where no one is in
a position to do anything about it
speaking of timing just as he stole the
valerian's Thunder Queen Alison has
decided that this is going going to be
her Knight to make a statement the king
starts to give a speech that is
interrupted when she UPS the stakes as
far as dramatic entrances are concerned
and walks to the table wearing Hightower
green they do a thing here where they
have hilaris explain what's happening to
his brother that the high tower burns
green when they're calling their banners
which I kind of wish they didn't have to
do but I guess it might not be clear
that the dress is important with
everything else that's going on if you
aren't already familiar with the story
this iconic green dress is her repping
the house she was born into instead of
the one she finds herself in and to top
things off she addresses rhaenyra as
stepdaughter there was a lot of chatter
about Rainier going as far as swearing
on her dead mother that she was still a
maiden in the last episode and this
indicates just how much of a betrayal
Allison sees that as one that led to her
father being removed as hand and that
left her alone in in King's Landing she
looks absolutely filled with rage but
the party must go on and we do see
things pick up there's a quick shot of a
dwarf playing a drum that is at the very
least a reference to mushroom the fool
from the book who wrote a lot of the
more salacious accounts of what was
going on in the story and we do see
rhaenyra and Lenor dance there's a lot
going on in the celebration but what
stood out to me the most was everyone's
faces as they're looking around Damon
Allison Kristen and Joffrey sir Gerald
does come back up to accuse Damon of
killing his wife but he gets pretty much
shut down we missed an opportunity there
to see two Warriors go up against each
other who both wield a Valerian steel
blade Damon has dark sister and house
Royce has lamentation we see Damon watch
renera like the creepy inappropriate
Uncle he is and he catches lady Lenor
looking at him he goes to her and he
opens with a line that was attributed to
Mushroom in the book where he says has
anyone ever told you that you're nearly
as pretty as your brother and there does
seem to be some chemistry going on
between these two characters in the
middle of everything Joffrey which is
not the best name to have when you're
thinking about a royal wedding in
Westeros thinks that he's figured out
Kristen is Ramirez Paramore so like you
do he just walks right up to him and
lets him know to his credit he thinks
their interests align and that he's
making a pack that will be beneficial to
everyone but as we'll learn later his
timing couldn't have been worse we see
Damon cut into a dance between rhaenyra
and Harwin strong she kind of outdamens
Damon by daring him to cut through the
kingsguard and take her to Dragonstone
to make her his wife he sort of grabs
her face as viserys looks on which
serves as a reminder that there is
Passion between these two that wasn't
just a fluke at the brothel then
everything gets interrupted did when
Kristen Cole beats Joffrey to death in
front of everyone apparently he snapped
Leonor even gets caught up in it we see
Harwin jump in to save rhaenyra but only
after his father tells him to do it and
yeah he just beats his face in
completely then no one stops him when he
walks out of the room I suppose this
ruins everything so they call in the
septon and he marries them that night
rather than waiting for the full week of
tourneys and everything else that was
supposed to happen so Kristen goes to
the godswood to kill himself but Alison
stops him and then during the wedding as
they're exchanging their vows with Lenor
essentially fighting through his
heartache because his lover just died
once again we see viserys pass out on
the floor then the episode comes to an
end as we see a rat come up to take a
taste of the blood that Joffrey Left
Behind compared to episode 4 I was a
little mixed on this one lore wise there
was a lot to like and as much as I never
cared much for Alison as a care
character in the book her arrival at the
wedding here was fantastic following
after Damon where you're still stuck in
the what the hell is he doing here mode
made this all the more memorable plus
high tide was really interesting Corliss
has collected all this strange stuff
from his adventures on the negative side
I think they leaned a little too far
into playing with our expectations
surrounding a westerosi wedding and even
though they set it up so everything
would make sense I felt that some of the
Kristen stuff it just felt contrived
they compressed some things in order to
have everything happen at this
celebration and after watching it the
first time I was just sort of like oh
okay that's a way you could bring things
together I guess I think the desired
effect was wow I didn't see that coming
and hell yeah we're getting back into
some real Game of Thrones action but the
green wedding didn't rise to the heights
of some of the other ones we associate
with colors and it felt like they were
trying to stoke my expectation and that
something was about to happen so much
that once it did actually come it was
just sort of like oh is that it the one
thing that makes sense in taking this
route though is it puts him in a place
where Allison has to rescue him he could
very well lose everything I mean that's
why he went to the godswood to take his
own life and her rescuing him will come
with the price of her basically owning
him which depending on how they play
that could lead to some interesting
situations because he is someone who
represents something that raniera cared
about at one time at least I do like the
emphasis on the messy nature of all
these unions that are made in the
interest of preserving power though
we've gotten to see some of the cases
where it worked out with viserys and
Emma and Corliss and rhaenys so you can
see where they wouldn't have that much
interest in changing the system and I
particularly liked rainey's calling
Corliss out on his motivations because
even though he's saying he's going to do
what's necessary to write the Injustice
she suffered she's moved on and knows
that it's more about power and wealth
for this man that she clearly loves
anyways we've seen the opposite end of
things with Damon and Ria which is funny
because that all seems to stem from her
being able to see through his BS to
their credit raniera and Lenor seem to
have a good plan to make the most out of
their situation and that made the somber
situation of their wedding and
especially his vows hit pretty hard also
as low born as Kristen Cole is in
relation to this person that he's
entered into this forbidden relationship
with it's not terribly surprising that
he would miss how she would never give
that up and then we have to ask
ourselves is this the way he would react
or is it common enough he should have
actually realized that hey this isn't
that bad of a situation the strongs are
some of my favorite characters in this
part of the story so it was fun to see
Laris working the situation with Allison
and the conversation between Lionel and
viserys I'm not not sure if their
intention is for us to suspect Laris as
the one who sent the tea or they're just
showing that he has those varus or
little finger characteristics of being
able to go in and find the weak link and
get the information off of different
people in different positions but I know
a lot of people were wondering if the
king actually sent that so this could be
something towards your answer a pretty
solid episode besides the somewhat
confusing and underwhelming ending and a
pretty solid first half of the season to
this point they've made these characters
far more compelling than they were in
the book without really changing their
nature I think that bodes well for the
future since the story does change gears
once the characters get older it's been
an interesting look at how they become
who they'll be I'm looking forward to
seeing how things play out and I think
that's a good place to leave things let
me know in the comments what you thought
about this episode and the first half of
the season if you haven't read the book
where do you think things are headed it
and if you have how do you feel about
some of the changes and what we're
learning about these characters compared
to what we knew from reading the book
book spoilers are fine please just use
LINE breaks to hide those under the fold
when you comment so that they won't
spoil anything for people who haven't
read ahead please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon